on here because this is gonna be fun you
can check out
cedric the entertainer tomorrow at the
amphitheater at craig
the amp dan
the amp the amphitheater over at craig
ranch park i believe mercedes sat down
with cedric earlier today with the
conversation take a look
cedric
[Music]
how are you doing
okay call it everything good how you
doing it is so good to have you on las
vegas now and even better back in las
vegas how long has it been since you've
been in town
oh man you know i mean you include the
panda gimmick it's been a couple of
years for sure i mean i've been there
you know i came just to hang out with
some friends you know but not to perform
it was uh i think this is when uh
hot the hard rock was a whole another
hotel do you remember the the first time
you actually performed in vegas on stage
you remember where it was
yeah it was the old sands
back in the day i'm gonna say this was
uh late 90s like maybe like 99 like you
know before prince made the song who was
one of the names that was the headline
name when you were the small name and
and what kind of advice did they give
you coming up in the business
well you know for me i've always come
you know
around uh with steve harvey being one of
my you know my my biggest kind of big
brother in the business and he was the
guy that gave me a lot of advice uh of
course there was david williams that was
king and williams you know so uh these
kind of guys um i never had a chance to
meet red fox but he was a person that i
aspired to when i think about vegas
because he always did those comedy
albums there and he was known he just
had that kind of marquee brand of being
known in vegas
here on cbs such a funny show you you do
that you are a writer okay comedian
actor writer producer um i was gonna say
you do everything but officiate weddings
but now i guess you do that
what's going on
yeah i had to check all the boxes right
you know so we go of course great
comedian my good friend russell peters
got married and uh he said man could you
appreciate my wedding i thought he was
joking he was like no it isn't
his
wife
now said yes we want you to do it and i
was like all right so you know i did
like everybody else i went online got
our name and uh studied up a little bit
beautiful ceremony great times i was
really honored to do it and we had a
blast doing it it was awesome they they
loved it was so apropos for who they are
as a couple it just really fit the mood
at the moment and uh it was perfect
so what's next are you going to be going
up with like jeff bezos to space or like
what what's next first everything
entertainment yeah exactly exactly i'm
going to try to do that i'm trying to
get over i'm going to do that i'm going
to get on the season the yellowstone i
want to ride a horse with kevin costa i
also hear you're a big wine guy like
what what is your wine of choice
well you know i actually have a
napa valley red that's mine called zetta
i've named it inspired by my mother uh
rosetta uh it's beautiful smooth
devilro.com anybody could go here and
get grab your zetas beautiful wine quake
uh that's me i'm wearing a red mine
uh cabernets big zinfandels uh i do like
a good pinot noir you know so uh but i
like that fruity you know flavor forward
you know enjoy it with a good meal
that's the kind of that's how i like to
drink wine
well i i heard that and i actually i
bought you a gift
and i'm hoping
yeah so let me show you what i have here
for you
i mean you are my favorite you are my
favorite comedian after all so i love
this
quintessa
we're gonna like maybe you can pour
yourself a little glass before you hit
the stage okay we will make that we'll
make that happen you're gonna make sure
it gets backstage to me now don't drink
that beforehand
she passes i think so she just got
backstage a bottle it was a quintessa
that'll get you anywhere you want to go
can i get any acn's just show that
exactly and now she's showing the bottle
of wine you're pouring red bull you know
really to
you can check out cedric the entertainer
that's tomorrow at the amphitheater at
craig ranch the show starts at six
o'clock you get tickets online at
jabment.com
that's gonna be good i love cedric